national security issues are dominating
president Trump's days including Iran's
nuclear program military operations in
Syria Russian aggressiveness the rise of
China and a high-stakes upcoming summit
with North Korea and next week he'll
host his third foreign leader in three
weeks my cover story this week in the
Atlantic explores the challenges of the
American presidency managing national
security is the most important one and
has gotten the most complex over the
years we spoke to three men who spent
much of their careers in national
security and government to help us
understand the challenges any president
faces how dangerous is the global order
for the president right now I think he
faces about the most challenging
situation we faced as a country
internationally since the end of the
Cold War Stephen Hadley worked in the
government under President Ford later
serving George Herbert Walker Bush in
the Pentagon and was his son george w
bush's advisor on national security for
close to a decade it's kind of like the
old plates spinner in the circus you
know a dozen plates on a narrow spindle
held up only because the spindles keep
spinning they can spin maker has to goes
from plate to plate to play it spin it
spin it spin it keep them from falling
I like the will to the best of my
ability being president has never been
easy but in the age of terrorism the
number of threats have multiplied and
Americans are vulnerable at home as
they've never been in national security
10,000 successes equals one failure jeh
Johnson was chief counsel to the
Secretary of Defense and served as
Secretary of Homeland Security we're
responsible for catching it all and many
days in Homeland Security whether you're
talking about a terrorist threat the
threat of a lethal virus cyberattack
spikes and illegal migration it's like
trying to catch raindrops to respond to
security issues a well-functioning White
House requires a stable and methodical
system the job is so large that there
has to be a certain structure to it to
ensure the
the Presidents Day is spent effectively
and efficiently and that he's making the
right decisions without a system
president severe from crisis to crisis
if all you do is respond to crises all
you will get is more crises because you
won't be able to take the time to put in
place the strategies and policies that
will shape the future in head off some
of these crises not every challenge in
the modern presidency is born overseas
changes in domestic politics have also
increased the friction in the job our
Congress is increasingly polarized there
is now virtue in politics over governing
and a president has given literally no
grace period in office I will faithfully
from day one there are people in the
opposition and want to see the president
fail and the very size of the White
House has become an impediment - thank
you mrs. Carr Joseph Califano was a top
aide to presidents Johnson
and Carter via the White House save up
to 2000 which is where they are now
you have 450 people in the National
Security Council the State Department's
overwhelmed you have close to a couple
hundred people in the domestic policy
staff you have 400 people in
communications so many issues get to the
president's throat because you've got
all these people working on these issues
that shouldn't really get there that are
better off left down and bureaucracy to
resolve so the president can focus on
the big strategy perhaps the biggest
challenge to the presidency is that we
have become a presidency obsessed nation
the framers designed a small limited
office now in many ways we expect one
person to represent a country of 327
million people so what should change
well where do you begin I think our
expectations to the office should change
we should think more about what a
president actually does in office when
we think about picking them and you talk
to anybody on both sides and they say
Congress needs to step back up and be
any co-equal branch of government not
really a branch that operates after the
president you think you would have
written the same piece of if Trump were
not president it started in the Obama
years it's and this is something you
know I did talk to people for over a
year in both parties and it
you know supporters of the president a
president Trump think you know he's
blowing through all the inefficiencies
of the White House of course his critics
say it's because he's doing so that it's
the problem that's what they call in the
business a good read well saying spins
into other things nicely done